And now it's the old scout master.
What did the necrotips say to the scout hat?
I have no idea. what did the necrotips say to the scout hat?
You go on ahead, I'll hang around here.
This is podcast number 72.
Music.
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Hey, if you've visited the blog
within the past two or three weeks, you notice the caption contest.
It was kind of an accident.
I got a funny picture from somebody
and I posted it on the blog and I said,
hey, we need a caption for this.
and that turned into a caption contest,
which was very well received,
and now that's turned into a weekly feature on the blog.
If you have a humorous scouting picture
that you think could be improved with a really funny caption,
send it to me
and we'll post it on the blog one week
and we'll give everybody a week to come up with the best caption
and then you can vote for your favorite caption
and then we will name a winner
and that winner, as well as the contributor of the picture,
will receive the coveted Kiber Pass.
Now I can't go into the entire history and tradition
and origin of the Kiber Pass on the podcast.
It would take too much time,
but I have recorded it on the blog
and I want you to go and take a look at it
at scoutmastercgcom when you have a chance
And participate in the caption contest.
It's great fun
and I wanted to mention that
because my first message came from Bill McFarlane,
who says:
I got my Kiber Pass last night
and I wanted to pass along my undying gratitude for it.
It's a great idea
and I love the humor.
Hmm,
Love the humor.
I don't know that the Kiber Pass is all that funny,
but okay,
Both the letter and the pass were laminated this morning
and will take a place of honor
in my equipment for summer camp this and every year.
Well, thanks, Bill.
That's Bill McFarlane wrote in.
He was a recipient of a Kiber Pass
for the contribution of a humorous scouting photo
And thanks very much, Bill.
I'm glad that you enjoyed and will enjoy
the honor of being a Kiber Pass recipient.
Tony Ratzel is an assistant scoutmaster
in Troop 457 in Memphis, Tennessee,
and he wrote in to say this:
Clark, I love the podcast as well as the articles.
They all help.
If every scoutmaster could hear all the podcasts
and read the articles,
it would be an outstanding training program.
I kind of liked it better
when you didn't have so many sponsors.
but hey, I realize why
and it's not too much of a distraction.
Well, thanks for writing in, Tony.
Thanks for the kind words.
We have to keep the doors open and the lights on
at the Scoutmaster blog and podcast facility,
So we certainly do appreciate it
when people do patronize our sponsors.
Jamie Humphries wrote in and said:
I just got the patrol method book this week
and read it in a couple of nights.
It's a really great book.
As I get a new Troop started this fall,
it will be the reference
for my assistant scoutmaster and committee.
Thanks for putting up the review and reference.
Well, Jamie is talking about a book
that everybody needs.
Every scout leader who's involved
with the Scout Troop at least
would greatly benefit from,
And that's a book called
Working the Patrol Method.
It's by Rob Ferris and Harry Wimbrow.
They were interviewed on a podcast last year.
We have a review.
It's a fantastic piece of work,
a fantastic reference
for working the patrol method
in the 21st century.
So do check out scoutmastercgcom
and make sure you get a look at the book.
And that segues into what we're spending
the rest of the podcast involved with
and that is a interview with
author, Mark Wray.
Now Mark is the author of
the scoutmaster's other handbook
and the Eagle Court of Honor book,
and another one that you might not have heard of
but you will have heard of
by the end of this podcast.
I really enjoyed talking with Mark last week.
He's a great guy
And I am happy to welcome him to the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we
Music?
Today we're talking with Mark Wray,
And Mark is the author
of the scoutmaster's other handbook,
the Eagle Court of Honor book.
Now, a lot of you know about those.
You've probably read his articles
in Scouting Magazine
or in the National Eagle Scouts Association's
Eagle Letter-
And we're going to talk about another book
that Mark wrote about.
that you probably don't know about,
but you should in just a moment.
Hey, Mark, how you doing?
I'm doing great. How about you, Clark?
Oh, we're doing all right.
You're down there in Louisville, Kentucky,
Is that right?
That's correct.
So down there in Louisville
it must be about as hot as it is here
in Kennett Square this morning.
Yeah, it's definitely summer camp season.
It's summer camp weather.
Let's say that. I'll give you that.
So tell me a little bit about
your background in Scouting, Mark.
Okay,
I joined Scouting in the third grade-
Back when Scouting still started
in the third grade-
And went all through the program
in Oxford and Mississippi
and became an Eagle Scout.
I worked with my home troop through college
and then, after I graduated
from my bachelor's program,
my master's program decided that
I would give professional Scouting a try,
And so I was a district executive
for about five years, both in Fort Myers, Florida,
and here in Louisville,
And enjoyed that a lot.
but as I went along
I realized that the things that I was really good at
and enjoyed were sort of the side projects
more than the fundraising and the recruiting
that are key to the district effectiveness job,
And so I jumped out of that
and back into the volunteer ranks
And then an adult volunteer
for about 25 years I guess,
mostly with Boy Scouting.
I was a scout master for five years
And I did a lot of things there
and currently I'm on our troop committee,
also on our PAC committee
and chair our Venturing Crew committee.
So I'm involved in all three sites of the program right now.
That's a lot of hat,
And a few others as well.
Not all that uncommon out there
in the world of Scouting
where a couple of different hats.
So somewhere along the way
you decided that we needed
another Scout Master's Handbook.
What about?
I guess a couple of things.
First of all,
especially when I was a district executive,
I would look around at a lot of Scout Masters
and realize that a lot of them were struggling,
Some were disorganized,
some were going it alone
and really didn't have the tools
to recruit and empower volunteers.
A lot of folks get really focused
on one or two of the methods of Scouting
and the exclusion of the others,
So they end up with a really unbalanced program.
Then, when I looked at the Scout Master Handbook-
the last several editions-
I realized that it's intended
primarily for new Scout Masters,
which is an intentional decision
that National has made
and makes sense, because those are the folks
that go to the Scout Shop
and are looking for resources
and they need to know the basics:
What is a patrol,
What is a troop,
What is a board review and so forth-
But there's not a lot in there
that talks about
so what do you do when things go wrong?
And that's the sort of information
that I wanted to give.
And also, over the years
I just picked up a lot of ideas
that I thought were valuable,
that I wanted to be able to share with folks.
What's some of the common feedback you get
or common questions you get about the book?
A lot of what I get
is from experienced leaders who say
I didn't think I'd find anything useful in here,
but there were really some things
that I found useful.
I think a common reaction is:
wow. this lets me know that I'm not alone.
Everybody runs into these same issues
that I've been dealing with,
Because you know,
one of the things that's interesting
about working in a Scout unit
is you often really have tunnel vision
and you just know what's happening in your unit.
You go around the table,
you see people at camp freeze and so forth,
But you rarely go to another troop's meeting
and see it in action.
But you don't realize
that everybody's dealing with common struggles.
It takes a little bit of an ego
to be a unit leader.
whether you're a Cub master or a Scout master or whatever.
We're not real likely to go looking for help
a lot of times.
Is there a particular part of the book
that you've gotten a lot of comments on
or that has been really
relevant for folks?
One of the sections of the book,
and also something that
one I've shot a film on,
has really seemed to be important to folks
is this idea of achieving some balance
in your program.
I guess it's a two-star process.
First of all
is remembering the distinction
between the aims and the methods.
The aims are citizenship, character
and fitness.
The methods are camping
and uniforming and advancement
and adult association
and all those sorts of things.
And some folks get those mixed up
and are so focused on
teaching kids how to camp
that they forget about developing character.
You've got these eight methods
and you've got to come up
with some sort of balance.
You can have an extreme where
you're so focused on developing youth leaders
that you're totally delegating
leadership to the PLC,
which is great,
but if they drop the ball
and you don't go camping all year,
things are really out of whack.
Or the other extreme:
is the Scott Masters really hands-on,
has a really really great
outdoor program,
but his junior leaders are figureheads?
Do we spend enough time on that
in leadership training? do you think?
I don't think we do.
I've been on a task force
at the national level
that specifically looking at how
we need the character development aim.
We don't spend a lot of time
talking about character.
We spend a lot of time talking
about camping techniques
and the administration
and so forth.
We don't really talk a lot
about intentionally teaching character.
One of the things
that we have done at Fillmont
is to hand out a worksheet
that has each of the values
from the oath and the law.
So we say, okay,
come up with a list of ways
that you can intentionally teach
the value of thrift
or the value of hearing loss.
And guys will say,
well, you could do a Scott Master Minute.
But when you get beyond that,
it really gets challenging.
When you start brainstorming,
you think, well,
there's some really neat stuff we could do.
talking about obedient:
Well, if we're going to be obedient
and we're going to set an example,
we probably should take our radar detectors
out of our cars
when we go on camping trips.
Yeah, there you go.
That hit though
Exactly.
And then somebody else said,
well, with trustworthy,
how about we don't have any padlocks
on our footlockers at summer camps?
There are some things
that we could intentionally do
that would model and teach these values
more than just giving a Scott Master Minute
at the end of the meeting
or repeating the oath and the law
at the opening.
And the other thing is you say,
well, they get the values naturally
in the program
And that's true,
But that doesn't mean that we can't push it along
a little bit more.
Tell me about your philosophy
of working with youth leaders
and what you think are the most important
two or three bullet points
for people to understand about that.
I think the first, most important point
is to have a really good understanding
of where your youth leaders are
and come up alongside them
and provide them the support that they need.
I had one senior patrol leader years ago
who was really a natural born leader-
such a thing-
and we would spend 20 minutes on the phone
talking about what was going to happen
Thursday night.
In the course of that conversation
he was prepared for that meeting
and I didn't really have to worry.
We've had other senior patrol leaders.
He almost had to stand beside and whisper:
okay, now it's time to do this,
Now it's time to do that,
And you've got to figure out
which approach works for that one scout
rather than just having a one-size-fits-all approach.
One of the more interesting statements
is: you point out that youth leadership
is a method and not an aim.
What does that mean?
It's interesting.
I think if you interviewed a lot of scout masters,
they would say that creating leaders
is what we're all about,
and it's really not
because a lot of our kids are not going to be
quote-unquote leaders in their life.
They're going to be followers
and we want them to be good followers
just as much as we want them to be good leaders.
And when we focus so much
on the youth leadership method,
I think that's where the other pieces
of the program can fall to the side.
One of the hardest achievements
for an adult leader
is being able to first see that that's important
and then actually be able to make it happen.
Let me add just one other thing
on working with youth leaders
that I think is really important.
Sometimes, when there's a work in the action,
when it's time for the closing
and nothing's happening,
our first reaction is to jump in there
and fix the situation.
But unless somebody's bleeding,
sometimes we just need to let things happen,
And that's where leadership is formed.
when those kids have to deal with those situations,
We need to give them the same opportunity
to figure that stuff out as we've had,
and sometimes that means not fixing it.
If you're sort of trigger happy,
maybe you've got to count to 10
or count to 50 before you do anything.
No, I'm pretty trigger happy, Mark,
I don't know about you.
I wanted to ask you about
rethinking the ideal patrol size.
You talk about the difference
between what's recommended as a patrol size
and what really works.
The program tells you that eight scouts
is the ideal patrol.
If you go to Wood Badge,
if you go to NYLT,
that's the ideal.
The problem these days
is that our kids so often are so over-scheduled.
I don't think in most cases
kids are making as many troop meetings
and outings as they did
when you and I were in scouts.
Suddenly, your eight scout patrol
gets reduced to three scouts
or four scouts or two scouts
on a camp out.
What people seem to usually do
is say: well, we'll combine
the shark patrol and the flaming air patrol
for this one camp out
and have a provisional patrol
which gets the job done,
but it destroys the patrol identity.
My argument is: one way to address that problem
is, instead of having eight guys in the patrol,
have 12 guys in the patrol, let's say,
with the idea that,
okay, if half of them don't show up on the camp out,
then you've got six
and that's enough to get the job done
without having to mess up the patrol's identity.
I think that's really wise.
I think things have changed significantly,
that we really need to look at patrol structure
in a different way.
The other book that we mentioned in the introduction
was the Eagle Court of Honor book.
How did that book come about?
That again goes back to my district executive days.
One of the things you do as a DE
is go to a lot of courts of honor,
and I went to some that were really good
and some that were pretty horrific.
Two cases in particular
that sort of crystallized the need for me
One. I went to a court of honor
where there were two scouts being recognized.
Somebody from the troop committee got up
at the end of the ceremony
and read all the congratulatory letters
that one of the scouts had received.
Then he read the other set,
which of course were identical word for word
to the first set.
Oh man,
I've read them all.
I have never experienced that before.
Kind of difficult courts of honor before,
but that's a new winner right there.
And then there was another one,
and this was actually in my district.
There was a set of twins
who were both receiving their badges
And for some reason in this ceremony
they had the guys go up on stage
at the very beginning and stand at attention.
Oh no,
Oh, I know how this goes.
Okay, go ahead.
I'm sorry.
At some point in the ceremony
the first one passed out.
Oh, no,
Almost, don't cue. the other one passed out,
Oh man,
Oh,
Yeah,
Yeah.
Well, that would be two good reasons
to write a book right there.
A third reason came up after I wrote it,
and I had no idea about this,
but there are many, many troops out there
that basically delegate the whole process
to the family.
Yeah,
How about that? huh,
Yeah.
I've heard from
I don't know how many parents who said:
I've never even been to an Eagle Court of Honor,
Mm-hmm,
And they want me to plan this thing.
Help,
Yeah,
What,
What of what?
The book is a collection of very practical advice
and then some scripts and things like that as well.
Mm-hmm,
What's your best advice for somebody
who's looking at scheduling
and presenting in an Eagle Court of Honor?
To go on my website.
I've got what's called
the Eagle Court of Honor Backdater.
It's a free interactive tool
where you plug in the date
that you're going to hold the Court of Honor
and it tells you basically everything that you need to do,
from the board review date
to sending thank you notes,
But it also helps put things in perspective,
Like you need to reserve the place
You're going to hold the ceremony first
before you submit an invitation.
You don't need to worry
about getting the programs printed
until much later in the process, for example
Mm-hmm.
So it gives you kind of a to-do list
and helps you make it a little bit simpler.
Exactly, yeah,
Okay,
Because I'll make sure to have a link to that.
What kind of feedback do you get
about the Eagle Court of Honor book?
People are thrilled.
What I like about it-
and I hope this is what people like about it as well-
is I sort of talk through the parts of the ceremony
and then I give people a bunch of mix and match
segments that they could plug in
to create a ceremony
unique for their recipient.
I think every Eagle Court of Honor
needs to be different
because every recipient is different.
Let's see if we can kill
a couple of urban legends
of scouting here real quick.
There's no official format that you have to follow
or anything like that,
And you don't even have to have a court of honor.
You are an Eagle Scout
once you pass the board review.
That's the second Urban Legend
is there's no kind of incantation
or ceremonial something or other
that happens at a court of honor
that makes somebody into an Eagle Scout.
That's probably when you look at the certificate
that comes from National.
the date that appears there is the board of review date,
because that's when you become an Eagle Scout.
The third book is maybe not quite so well known
as the first two.
It's called
Growing Up Right, Growing Up Strong-
The Parents' Guide for Scouting.
How did that come about?
It's part of the Scout Parents' Initiative,
which was actually started
by a longtime scouter named Gerald Longhorn
passed away a couple of years ago.
He had this vision that
parents needed to be more a part
of the scouting program
And basically what we wanted to do in the book
is help people understand
how scouting supports the family.
So I interviewed parents of Scouts
literally from around the world,
because we tracked some folks down
who have been involved in scouting
as expatriates in the military
and talked about what scouting does for kids,
what scouting does for families
and what scouting does for parents.
in that sort of a call to action
of what parents can do for scouting,
Put together sort of a little decision tree
that folks who are thinking about getting involved
can use to figure out how the best could serve.
So it's got categories-
How much time do you have available?
Do you prefer to work with your son,
with adults, bookkeeping and finance-
and then it sort of directs them
from those attributes to particular positions
in the unit where they could serve.
And this book is free.
We can download it as a PDF file.
There'll be a link on the post
that contains this podcast.
You made it up to the National Jamboree last year.
I did,
And what did you do there?
I was on the staff
at the National Eagle Scout Association booth.
What was happening at the booth?
But the real highlight was that
just about every day, we had at least
one nationally prominent Eagle Scout on hand.
Oh, okay,
And those guys were extremely gracious
to sign autographs, to answer questions.
Some of them would get up on the podium
and speak for a few minutes,
And then the real highlight was
that we presented the Distinguished Eagle Scout Award
to Colonel Charles McGee,
who is one of the original Tuskegee Airmen
from World War II.
Planning on going in 2013 up to the summit,
I think. so
I'm excited about what's going on there
and really want to get a look at it firsthand.
You've been around scouting now
for 25, almost 30 years as a leader.
What do you think has changed significantly
about scouting?
I think technology and how we do training,
how we communicate with our kids-
that's really changed, potentially for the better.
I think in terms of the organization,
the summit is a really good example
of how, more than ever, we're really looking
at what kids want and need
and tailoring the program to meet their needs
and also to be maybe more relevant
and exciting than it was 30 years ago.
Been really exciting to see that
and I think that's going to carry through
across the organization.
If I gave you the ability to talk to every new scout leader
and you had 30 seconds to talk to them
and tell them everything that you know,
what would be the most important points you would hit on?
You are uniquely positioned to make a real difference
in some young person's life,
More than their parents, perhaps
more than their Sunday school teacher, perhaps
certainly more than their soccer coach
or their piano teacher
or their teacher in school.
There are just so many examples of folks
who look back and say that their life
was drastically changed
because of an adult who took an interest in them
and saw potential in them.
I guess I would say: stick with it.
It's a hard job-
That's why we get paid so much-
But impact kids' lives
and you can impact the future of our country
and train the world as a result.
That is excellent advice.
It sets the entire stage
for everything you're going to do. as a volunteer leader,
You're uniquely positioned
to be able to actually make a difference.
I really like that.
That's a good choice.
Let me share a little story related to that.
One of the folks that I interviewed a while back
for the Eagle Letter was a guy named Chuck Smith
and when he was growing up
in inner city Los Angeles-
in the 50s I guess it was-
he was shy, he was dyslexic,
he had learning disabilities,
but he wanted to be somebody
and to do something. and he went up to his teacher
and shared with her that he wanted to go to college
and maybe get into radio
or the space program or something.
and she looked at him and said:
get out of here. you're going to be lucky
if you can get out of high school.
He was crushed by that, obviously.
but his parents had a friend
who was a ham radio operator
and was a scout master
and this guy said to Chuck:
you can not only learn about radio
but you can learn about life
and I've got just the organization for you,
which, of course, was scouting.
Chuck learned about radio.
he learned about communications
a couple of years ago, retired as the president
of AT&T West,
and he's been an incredible mentor
to a lot of inner city young people
who are in the same situation that he was in,
and that all happened because that one scout leader
took an interest in him and saw the potential.
It is pretty awesome and not in the
late 1980s sense of the term,
but it is like really awesome
what can happen and the kind of influence
and the good that a person can do
as a scouting volunteer.
Well, I really appreciate you spending the time with us.
I know that everyone who listens to the podcast
will be interested to hear from you.
A lot of them have your books and if they don't,
there will be a way to find them.
if you go to scoutmastercgcom
and you look at the post that contains this podcast,
We'll have links to all of Mark's work
and his website and the free resources that he mentioned.
Mark, I really do appreciate you taking the time.
Well, thanks so much. I appreciate it.
Thanks for listening. Now here's how to keep in touch.
You can read the Scoutmaster blog
and subscribe to the Scoutmaster newsletter
at scoutmastercgcom.
Now, the newsletter comes by email every month
and it has some great scouting resources
around a monthly theme.
This month in June, it's going to be summer camp.
We also have a giveaway in every newsletter.
Our interviewee, Mark Ray, donated some copies of his book,
the Scoutmaster's Other Handbook,
for our giveaway this month.
So go to scoutmastercgcom,
Make sure you're subscribed.
This month's newsletter is going to go out next week.
You can subscribe to this podcast on iTunes
and you can leave a comment
or review a rating there.
You can also call and leave a voicemail, comment or question
at 848-734-0002.
We're on Facebook at Scoutmaster blog
and Scoutmastercg on Twitter.
Now, the Scoutmaster blog and podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
Hey, it's just me.
I have a microphone and I enjoy trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders and perhaps have a little bit of fun along the way.
Now, before we go, let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pal.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.